this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 34 Echo Charles and myself Jaco
willink uh sitting around I've get a
periodic question
we start talking people start talking to
me about what's my Five-Year Plan what's
my 10-year plan this like long-term
strategic plan how do you go about that
what does it involve what is that
planning how's that planning take shape
how do you format it like these kind of
questions so I want to talk about it a
little bit the the Shocker statement
which is sort of dramatic
overly dramatic because it's only
partially true and kind of true which is
I don't do that and so you know
sometimes I'll say that for a little
shock value or because I want to impress
I think I'm not for shocked I say it to
people because I want to impress upon
them that
I don't do it the way a normal person
would do it part of the reason for that
is the
I think what one of the lessons that I
learned in combat is that overly
detailing plans
they're not going to be possible to
follow I mean and this might be you know
this is even a one operation that's
going to last three hours if you make a
super detailed plan and you invest a lot
of time and effort and trying to make
make a super detail plan
chances are you're not going to be able
to execute it what's better is to make a
flexible plan with some broad goals so
you understand what it is you're trying
to get done and and then go execute with
some flexibility
so
looking at your life or your business
and being like okay well I need a five
to ten year strategic plan I kind of
apply the same thing I'm gonna look for
some overall long-term
strategic goals
of where I want to be and then I'm going
to explore
different opportunities to get me there
to satisfy that mission
I might make loose plans about
what I'm going to try and do
but I'm not gonna over commit to any
plans too that's another thing
there's not some idea that I have that I
that I'm committing to which is weird
it's backwards from what people think
right you've got to commit right and you
do got to commit
sort of like in Jiu Jitsu you you if I
do a sweep because I want to expose your
arm but I don't really commit to this
people then you don't even defend it
your arm doesn't stick out so I can't
get your arm yeah I need to actually try
that'll expose another opportunity if I
don't actually try there's not going to
be opportunities so I'm not saying you
don't have to commit to things that
you're going for but
I don't try and sweep you and then when
you don't get swept I don't just keep
trying to keep trying to keep trying to
use all my energy and by the way now I'm
exposing myself to a bad situation
so that's sort of like the way I look at
long-term sort of goals in life and five
ten years
six years ago
we didn't have a podcast
this wasn't a thing six years ago I
didn't have any books hadn't read any
books
didn't have anything to sell wasn't
selling anything
I had Echelon front but it was just Leif
and me
so we had a consulting company but it
was two people
now now
I got what I don't know 10 something
books multiple podcasts we got origin we
got Jocko fuel we got a warrior kid I
got real estate things going on I got
Jocko publishing Echelon front is now a
bunch of people
Online Academy extreme ownership Academy
the FTX going on at Echelon front the
the battlefield stuff that we do the
most there's all kinds of things going
on
and if you would have asked me six years
ago
if I would have a clothing Factory in
North Carolina
I would have said well I guess that
could happen or a boot Factory we're
going to make boots in America might
have said okay you know that's I that
seems like
okay if you would have told me I would
have been selling energy drinks
throughout the country I would have said
okay so there's a lot of things are
going on that might have been hard to
predict right
so what am I doing I'm looking for
opportunities
looking for opportunities and then apply
some resources some not over committing
but apply some resources and then run a
feedback loop
and run a quick feedback loop and what
kind of feedback are you getting is the
product that you made good
are people listening to the podcast
are people
contacting Echelon front to have us help
them with their leadership oh no one's
contacting us okay well maybe the
product that we're making isn't that
desired oh a ton of people are
contacting us okay maybe we should hire
some other instructors oh we got some
more instructors and they're they're
working overtime okay maybe we need some
more oh okay we we're gonna make
t-shirts
well no one buys the t-shirts okay well
maybe people don't want t-shirts that
say discipline equals freedom on okay oh
we made t-shirts that say discipline
equals freedom and a lot of people are
buying them okay cool let's make some
more of those let's make a sweatshirt
that says those
should we make 50 000 sweatshirts that
says that no because we don't know how
many people are gonna buy them how about
we just make 2 000 right now oh those
all sold okay well how about you see
what I'm saying so you you you you
experiment a little bit you take some
risk
but you don't take too much risk
I didn't say hey you know I think I'm
gonna make t-shirts I'm gonna buy a
factory tomorrow
sure right I'm going to employ a hundred
people to sell
like that's not what we're doing but
here so so now I'm saying all that
but as I went through all that there's a
there's a really important part of this
and that is
number one keep an open mind right
because these opportunities are going to
present themselves in your life you got
to keep an open mind that also
reinforces the idea of not committing
over committing on things but also you
have to occasionally
periodically more than occasionally
periodically you have to review what
you're doing
tactically like this day this week this
month to make sure it's getting you
where you want to be strategically
and then you need to assess and adjust
assess and adjust assess and adjust so
if you and I started this podcast and we
were like okay you know hey that was
pretty cool and then we invited on uh
somebody that was in charge of pet uh
animals uh veterinarian right and then
we were like okay hey that was cool and
the veterinarian was cool to talk to so
then all of a sudden we're like hey
let's do the next one in the
veterinarian's shop and we can hopefully
get some of these animals that are uh up
for adoption we can get them adopted
right and so like cool and then all of a
sudden we look up in two years and we're
running an adoption agency for pets I
got nothing against pets I want I don't
want dogs to get put down from the pound
but
if my main effort in life was helping
stray dogs get uh adopted again that's a
great effort but it wouldn't be what I
would want to concentrate on
so instead of getting two years down the
road
in a month I'd I'd say hey Echo man I
know we just did two podcasts inside of
a vet inside of a inside of a dog pound
which is cool it was fun but
I don't know if that's strategically
where I want to be
right so make those adjustments
make those adjustments because otherwise
you could end up looking up in three
four five years and you're involved in
something that you don't even like yeah
you don't even want to be involved in it
dogs are better I like dogs it's a bad
example I should have said something
else but that's what came out of my
mouth so we gotta stick with it
we don't have to stick with it we could
adjust what would be what could have
what could have pulled us off the path
what could we got into flower shop
flower shops right we like flowers we
like flowers but we don't want to be
pulling weeds all day and and trying to
talk about here's the problem with that
I'm not truly interested in flowers
right more interesting that's a that's a
great one actually flowers are fine
Gardens are fine
it's not my scene it's not I'm not into
it it's for sure not aligned with the
original group of goals that you had
yeah but let's say you know we did one
and I started talking about you know if
you want to be a Survivor if you want to
be able to survive you got to be able to
grow plants right and then all of a
sudden hey you know I'd love to come on
your Talk podcast and talk about uh you
know Hydroponics oh yeah
so we bring online guests and all of a
sudden he's like yeah you know you
should do the next one I'll come and
give you a tour of my intern internal
Farm you see what I'm saying next thing
you know I'm talking about weeds and
freaking root length soil composition
stuff that I'm not really into yeah
again if you're into it hype good I'm
glad because you can grow food for me
yeah yeah so don't let yourself get too
far down a path
that's why you got to run you got to
detach and you got to assess what you're
doing yeah that's because and also other
people in your little group if you have
a group or whatever they can kind of
pull you too you I mean I I've found
anyway they you gotta watch out and this
is advice to me like right now what
you're saying you're talking to me as
far as so you don't really like this
podcast that we do
no sir that's uh that's that's a one of
the good parts well actually here's
something
do you like
running fulfillment and stocking shelves
do you like doing that well that was one
uh no no no no I don't so what's good is
you did that for a little while yes we
did that for a little while mostly you
right
you realized hey this isn't like a great
effort this isn't a great use of my time
I don't love doing it do you like making
videos yes
and you still make videos yes sir is
that a good use of your time I think so
you enjoy it yes sir so you you steered
yourself away from
stalking shipping Packaging
yeah and by the way we have a friend
that does that and is into it I'm like
cool right on let's help build your
business good to go Ryan right
hey Ryan go right on he's got a business
he's into it he's making that work he's
got a team like that's good stuff
wasn't really Echo Charles's scene right
perhaps we could say maybe no offense
maybe it wasn't even your skill set
I'm always down to learn because it was
you know kind of a thing that requires a
timely commitment yes execution yeah
let's say my skill set at the time yeah
and even maybe at this time what you
know was not up to the standard that I
think it it probably should have took
yep and it's not a good fit so this is a
good leadership point if I've got Echo
Charles at my company and echo's good at
creating things he's good at coming up
with ideas but he's not the kind that
shows up you know early and is like
executing that project on time why am I
putting him in charge of fulfillment
yeah well we're not going to do that
we're going to put him in charge of
making videos or something like this
so there you go good
I think this is important stuff for
people to know yeah yeah so any if you
um you know how like
if you have a group of people or
whatever and then they say oh shoot we
need someone to um I don't know do this
task that's not a consistent task that
needs to be done it's just one kind of
you know one-off task and then just a
quick it's not a deep evaluation it's
just it kind of comes up like okay oh
Echo could probably do it given the fact
that he knows about this this and this
so he could probably at least give me
some advice right so they go to Echo and
then so now I'm there
quote-unquote giving advice my best
opinion or whatever and it seems like
dang that's a good opinion then they'll
be like kind of in the back of their
mind hey let's sort of task him with
this in general you know this come to
him for this kind of stuff in general
and of course me being the you know the
team when trying to help or what do you
call I'm a go with guy right of course I
mean most of the time anyway so I'll be
like oh yeah cool yeah
do that right now and then the next week
yeah sure I'll do it and then two months
later that's like I'm on the hook for
doing that now and it's like dang I
didn't even I thought I I wanted to do
this other stuff you just took
everything I said and turned it into how
to get out of work
well the thing is you just said all of a
sudden you're on the hook for stuff yep
it's true you don't like that bro that's
how it feels if you get caught down one
of these little rabbit holes or however
you put it where you look up and you're
like wait a second this isn't part of my
plan at all I just kind of got sucked in
and you did get sucked or you allowed
yourself to get some I'm talking to
myself
it's a total Mission creep scope creep
Mission creep freaking all that stuff
and you look up because you don't want
to let nobody down you know I'm just
saying other people can suck you down
that hole I give you a 9 out of ten for
put like stopping that from happening
well that one there was this one period
at time where I actually even came to
you and it was like hey
this is what I'm thinking as far as like
stopping certain things or getting
getting less and less involved in
certain things but um like I said to me
you're talking to me because that's like
a constant thing I think well a good
thing to uh pay attention to
let's get to some q a what do you got
and
answers
I start bouncing soon at a bar
all right and I want to get insight from
both you especially I could do this
experience working in The Nightlife yeah
I'm 23 years old which is literally the
age I started or I started here in San
Diego I was younger in Hawaii I'm 23
year old 5 10 and about 210 same
dimensions as me more or less
I've been training both Muay Thai and
the Jiu jits for about four years
training anywhere from four to six times
a week I feel relatively confident in
physical altercation altercations though
I tend to avoid them at all costs
a friend of mine who also I train with
owns a couple restaurants and said he'd
love for me to bounce for him because
I'm extroverted quote extroverted quote
unquote extroverted good with people and
tend to be pretty good at de-escalating
situations
my problem is how much
how much I hate confrontation while it's
good to have the traits I mentioned
before I find that I'm often really bad
at being stern or putting my foot down
when needed and this is obviously a
necessary skill for a bouncer looking
for some advice that either of you think
might help thanks guys go ahead there no
no no no please go ahead there [__]
to help me
bro I was watching that house the other
day and bro that he's he's is
sensationalizing in a bunch of ways but
he's right his speech yeah be nice it's
not personal like all this stuff
yeah we could pretty much just roll the
Dalton speech from Roadhouse right now
yes sir and what's interesting about
this is you know I what do I think I
think well make sure you learn how to
detach don't take things personally
train Jiu Jitsu you're already trained
in jiu jitsu what's good is it seems
like you actually might have
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the the Jocko underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
at Jocko underground.com and we'll get
you taken care of until then we
mobilized
Underground